und jetzt hoffe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 37 37 beratung
mehrerer vorlage zur förderung von
betriebsratswahlen und der
betriebsratsarbeit in einer digitalen
arbeitswelt für die aussprache sei eine
dauer von 30 minuten beschlossen haben
die aussparen detail das model kollegin
katja mast spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ohne
mitbestimmung durch betriebsräte gebe es
weniger sicherheit bei der arbeit ohne
mitbestimmung ging in deutschland
deutschland deutlich weniger ohne
mitbestimmung wären wir nicht
serienweise exportweltmeister und ich
zitiere denn eine gesellschaft die sich
wirtschaftlich und sozial nach vorne
bewegen will ist ohne mitbestimmung und
die dazugehörige mitverantwortung nicht
denkbar wer hat das gesagt
helmut schmidt einer der größten
sozialdemokraten überhaupt er hat
gemeinsam mit vielen anderen mit
bestimmungen damit deutschland groß
gemacht das hat die soziale
marktwirtschaft mit leben gefüllt mit
schmidt mit schmitts
mitbestimmungsgesetz kamen 1976
arbeitnehmervertreterinnen vertreter in
die aufsichtsräte von unternehmen ein
meilenstein übrigens kamen durch ein
gesetz von manuela schwesig die frauen
dazu auch das war richtig moderne
wirtschaft kann nicht von oben diktiert
werden sie braucht mit sprache diesem
gedanken entspricht dass betriebsräte
modernisierungsgesetz von unserem
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil in
dem es
die gründung von betriebsräten
vereinfacht zweitens mitbestimmung nicht
nur bei der weiterbildung im betrieb
erleichtert drittens digitale arbeit von
betriebsräten ermöglicht und viertens
wahl prozesse in betrieb verschlang
dieses betriebsräte
modernisierungsgesetz ist ein starkes
bekenntnis zur demokratie im betrieb es
ist ein bekenntnis zum mut derer die
einen betriebsrat gründen wollen auch
wenn die zeichen auf sturm stehen
die spd hat sehr zäh verhandelt über den
koalitionsvertrag hinaus und vom ersten
tag in dieser koalition an war für uns
klar dieses gesetz muss kommen
zu oft so oft hören wir wer im begriff
ist einen betriebsrat zu gründen wird
vorher entlassen oder weggemobbt das ist
untragbar
das geht nicht mit diesem betriebsräte
modernisierungsgesetz gibt es nun einen
früheren breiteren kündigungsschutz für
alle die betriebsräte gründen wollen
dieses gesetz dieses gesetz ist
ausdrücklich eine ermutigung zur
gründung von betriebsräten und wo wir
schon dabei sind legen wir beim
arbeitsschutz auch noch nach wer sein
kind im home office zur kita bringt
genießt von nun an gesetzlichen
unfallversicherungsschutz dieses gesetz
sagt danke an alle betriebsrätinnen und
betriebsräte danke es ermutigt sich
demokratisch für die beschäftigten rhein
zu knien und für die arbeitsplätze
es zeigt respekt vor dieser
ausserordentlichen täglichen leistungen
im betrieb und deshalb danke ich zum
schluss noch mal allen die dazu
beigetragen haben
allen voran unserem arbeitsminister
hubertus heil und heute ganz besonders
meiner kollegin kerstin tack
[Applaus]
externe ist die kollegin beatrice steht
der präsident wertete kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe zuschauer
herr minister heil am ende der
legislaturperiode stellt sich die frage
wie ihre bilanz aussieht in ihren augen
wahrscheinlich positiv doch leider sehen
dass diejenigen die von ihrer politik
betroffen sind häufig ganz anders eine
partei die ehemalige volkspartei die
unter dem deckmantel der
sozialdemokratie den großen wohltäter
spielt trägt ihren namen schon lange
nicht mehr rechnungen von 1000 euro die
sie dem bürger aus der tasche ziehen
geben sie ihm dann gnädigerweise 100
wieder zurück dass sie mich hier ein
beispielhafte glanzleistung ihres
schaffens nennen die sogenannte respekt
rente hier haben sie so viele wenn und
aber eingebaut
könnte doch einfach zu frau kollegin den
können sie noch was lernen haben sie so
viele wendungen aber ein gebraucht das
von den 1,3 millionen rentner die
überhaupt nur in frage kämen diese
respekt rente überhaupt nur wenige
beziehen können ich nenne das eine
mogelpackung der durchschnittliche
aufschlag den ein rentner durch ihre
respekt rente bekommen könnte beträgt 75
euro
damit haben sie in euro ausgedrückt was
in respekt gegenüber alten armen
menschen wert ist er ein
die liste lässt sich beliebig erweitern
das würde allerdings dann meine redezeit
sprengen alle ihre gesetze dienen dazu
ihre reputation als arbeitsminister und
die ihrer partei mit spiegelfechtereien
und potemkin dörfern dem wähler als
partei der sozialen gerechtigkeit zu
verkaufen
das einzige was er der spd noch soziales
ist die verstrickung mit sozialverbänden
und gewerkschaften wenn es um die
lukrative verteilung von posten und
ämter für die genossen geht und nun zu
guter letzt viel arbeitsminister heil
seinen gewerkschafts freunden ein
abschiedsgeschenk hinterlassen dass
betriebsräte modernisierungsgesetz ein
paar vernünftige aspekte kann das gesetz
in der tat vorweisen ich nenne hier zum
beispiel die erleichterung der
betriebsrats gründung und der wahl sowie
den damit verbundenen schutz der daran
beteiligten arbeitnehmer ebenso stehen
wir alternativen der ausweitung des
sonderkündigungsschutz positiv entgegen
um etwaige behinderung von
betriebsratswahlen zu vermeiden
mit der vereinfachung der digitalen
betriebsratsarbeit wurde ein schritt
vollzogen der schon lange überfällig war
und gerade in dieser von der regierung
zu verantwortenden unsicheren krisenzeit
mit kurzarbeit massenentlassungen und
unbestimmten zukunftsaussichten
unverzichtbar ist allerdings hat das
beamers hier einen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt der als zu einem starken
regulatorischen eingriff in das
bisherige betriebsverfassungsrechtliche
regelungssystem führt hubertus heil
lieblingsthema der letzten monate das
mobile arbeiten mit dem hier
eingeräumten mit
stimmungs recht für betriebsräte bei
mobiler arbeit erleben wir einen
massiven eingriff in weisungsrecht
vertragsfreiheit sowie unternehmerische
freiheit
wie schon bei den plänen zur mobile
arbeit gesetz wird hier den
betriebsräten ein mitbestimmungsrecht
gewehrt dass man nicht mehr
mitbestimmungsrecht nennen kann ich
nenne es ein dekret gegenüber der
betriebsleitung vielen dank oberwittler
source der spd-fraktion der sich zu
beginn eher weniger mit dem thema
mitbestimmung beschäftigt hat oben
festzustellen dass amtszeit von hubertus
heil dem bundesarbeitsminister keine
gute gewesen sei um dann aber wiederum
dem gesetz zur betrieblichen
mitbestimmung doch zitat ein paar
vernünftige aspekte abzugewinnen um dann
anschließend wieder von einem dekret zu
sprechen nun peter weise sehr nicht so
redner aus der unionsfraktion der
sprecher für arbeit und soziales einen
betriebsrat zu haben ist ein großer
vorteil unser für den arbeitgeber wie
für die beschäftigten
das haben wir jetzt vor allen dingen die
seiten sehen in der korona pandemie wo
ein betriebsrat ist kann ich schneller
und einfacher vereinbarungen treffen zb
zur einfachen einführung der kurzarbeit
und zu vielem anderen mehr
also gerade dieser krise die wir
durchlebt haben indem wir die kurzarbeit
angewandt haben zeigt sich wie
vorteilhaft ist ist ein betriebsrat zu
haben
und wenn sich jetzt auch keiner hat uns
gewünscht hat wer die kolleginnen
kollegen dass wir auf diese pandemie und
die wirtschaftlichen folgen
mit der kurzarbeit antworten konnten
dass betriebsräte und arbeitgeber zu
trauern haben zur zukunft und nicht zu
entlassungen noch kurzarbeit greifen
das an der brücke zur seitlichen
leistungen in diesen jahren und auf den
wir zu recht stolz und können stolz sein
wir modernisieren dieses betriebsräte
gesetzt und in der tat wir ziehen auch
einige konsequenzen aus dem was wir
erlebt haben betriebsräte haben wir
erlaubt auch online zutaten
wir stellen es ihnen frei rechtssicher
das auch in zukunft machen zu können und
wir vereinfachen das wahlverfahren damit
auch vereinfachungen der bildung eines
betriebsrates und verstärke den
kündigungsschutz für diejenigen die eine
betriebsrats initiative ergreifen
wir klären noch einmal die
datenschutzrechtlichen verantwortung
wir stärken das recht der betriebsräte
hinblick auf welt initiativen zur
berufsbildung
und wir senken das mindestalter nachdem
wir schon mal personalvertretungsgesetz
das gemacht haben gleiche das jetzt auch
beim dritt verfassungsgesetz an was die
wahlberechtigung auch der jüngeren
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter in einem
betrieb anbelangt und jetzt sowas dem
mobilen arbeiten das ob mobiles arbeiten
ein beet etabliert wird ist selbst
wahrscheinlich eine aufgabe des
arbeitgebers und es bleiben das aber das
wieder ausgestaltung ist doch
selbstverständlich
meiner auffassung nach einige heute
schon eine aufgabe weil der betriebsrat
sehr wohl mit senat insbesondere wenn
vereinbarungen getroffen werden die alle
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter eines
betriebs erfassen von daher auch das
eine logische fortentwicklung und es
zeigt dass wir auf die herausforderungen
der digitalen zukunft auch im
betriebsverfassungsgesetz eine gute und
sachgerecht antwort geben
mit all diesen einzelregelungen die wir
mit dem neuen betriebsverfassungsrecht
schaffen stärken wir die betriebsräte
eher wundern wenn die mitarbeiterin wird
dabei dass ich ihn nach betriebsräten zu
engagieren
und natürlich gilt artikel 2 des
betriebsverfassungsgesetzes zu seinen
mantel und schirm über allem weiterhin
nämlich dass betriebsrat und arbeitgeber
zu vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit
verpflichtet sind
diese zusammenarbeit erhält durch unser
neues gesetz neue schubkraft und neue
motivation vielen dank peter weiss aus
der unionsfraktion mit seiner sicht der
dinge nächster redner habe jetzt einen
carl julius cronenberg aus der fdp
fraktion und der hat in einer ersten
beratung dieses gesetzes im anfang mai
dieses jahres hier schon gesagt dass
hunderttausende von betrieben
schlichtweg keine notwendigkeit für
einen betriebsrat sehen weil sie
vertrauensvoll und partnerschaftlich mit
der geschäftsleitung zusammenarbeiteten
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen seit 100
jahren ist die betriebliche
mitbestimmung tragende säule der
sozialpartnerschaft in deutschland die
letzte reform des
betriebsverfassungsgesetzes liegt 50
jahre zurück die letzte änderung 20
jahre kein wunder dass viele regelungen
verstaubt und aus der zeit gefallen
erscheint eine reform ist überfällig
allerdings ist mitbestimmung zu wichtig
und so wertvoll dass sie es verdient
hätte kurz vor dem wahlkampf nur
halbherzig modernisiert zu werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wer auch in zehn jahren wir auch in zehn
jahren noch starke mitbestimmung bild
der muss heute den rahmen setzen der den
betrieblichen bedürfnissen von morgen
gerecht wird und genau das leistet das
gesetz nicht passiert es wird dem regen
modernisierung an spuren leider nicht
gerecht
ok sitzungen der videokonferenzen
dauerhaft zu lässig oder auch zeit ein
drittel schritt in die richtige richtung
an der aber sofort der aber sofort
wieder dadurch relativiert wird dass es
an gesetzlichen vorrang von präsenz
sitzungen gibt warum so mutlos
auch das recht auch hinzuziehung eines
externen sachverständigen bei einführung
von künstlicher intelligenz stärkt den
betriebsrat nur auf dem papier
in wahrheit riskiert die regelung zu
reinigungsprozesse allein darüber was
genau ist und wir dafür als
sachverständiger in frage kommt mehr und
längere konflikte sind vorprogrammiert
das ist das gegenteil dessen was
betriebe in zeiten der transformation
brauchen eine schnelle entscheidungen
auf grundlage von vertrauensvoller
zusammenarbeit peter weiß hat dazu
ausgeführt
das gesetz verfehlt schließlich auch
sein ziel weil es auf eine wichtige
klarstellung
87 absatz 1 nummer 6 verzichtet wenn
heute software rsa die technik check in
apps kurz jede neue technik theoretisch
auch dazu geeignet ist leistung von
beschäftigten zu kontrollieren dann
heißt das noch lange nicht dass sie auch
dazu bestimmt wird
wenn ich ein brotmesser kauf durch das
um damit und zuschneiden und nicht um
die auslandshilfe einzuschüchtern
geeignet ist eben nicht bestimmt das
muss modernst mitbestimmungsrecht
endlich würdige mitbestimmung darf nicht
zum symbol für technologie skepsis und
innovationsstau werden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der koalition in summe
modernisiert das gesetz zu zaghaft stadt
an der falschen stelle und tut gar nicht
nötig wäre
so bleibt mitbestimmung insbesondere für
junge betriebe und junge beschäftigte
unattraktiv wird bei demokraten fordern
stattdessen einfache online wahlen
sitzungen im digitalformat ohne präsenz
vorrang und beschlüsse im umlauf
verfahren was im aufsichtsrat erlaubt
ist sollte das im betriebsrat schon
einmal sein
ein letzter ein letzter punkt zum
nachdenken wenn sich der gesetzgeber
ständig in die angelegenheiten der
sozialpartner einmischt dann darf er
sich nicht wundern wenn mitbestimmung
und tarifbindung auf dem rückzug sind
achten sie tarifautonomie
achten sie subsidiarität und
beschränkten sie sich bei der anpassung
der gesetze auf die bedürfnisse der
betrieblichen lebenswirklichkeit von
morgen
damit erreichen sie mehr als mit diesem
gesetz carl julius kronberger das aus
der fdp-fraktion und das wiederholt
schon gefallen
stichwort ab kürzel ki künstliche
intelligenz so wollte ich vielleicht
einen kleinen satz wenigstens darauf
verschwinden es geht darum dass
mitbestimmung da garantiert bleibt auch
wenn personal durch programme also durch
künstliche intelligenz ausgewählt wird
und dann eingestellt werden so jutta
krellmann ist am pult die linke
sprecherin für mitbestimmung und arbeit
und vielleicht haben sie sich wohl schon
bei uns gesehen
zur chemie laborantin begonnen einen
monat später bin ich mitglied der
gewerkschaft geworden genauso wie 90
prozent meiner mit auszubildenden die zu
der zeit angefangen haben 1972 wurde
auch das betriebsverfassungsgesetz mit
leben erfüllt betriebliche mitbestimmung
war zu der zeit politisches ziel
arbeitgeber liefen sturm gegen die ihf
gegen dieses vorhaben und heute in
zeiten der globalisierung und
deregulierung ist davon nichts mehr zu
spüren
heute haben wir befristungen leiharbeit
hartz 4 und arbeitgeber die regelrecht
betriebsräte bekämpfen
nach aktuellen zahlen von mittwoch haben
nur noch acht prozent der betriebe einen
betriebsrat 8 prozent das ist eine
katastrophe und nichts anderes
die regierungsparteien frauen seit
vielen jahren zu wie die betriebliche
mitbestimmung dem dach abgeht
das betriebsverfassungsgesetz wurde
nicht auf die neuen herausforderungen
der globalisierten arbeitswelt angepasst
aktuelles beispiel die firma primark in
hannover
dort soll der aktive
betriebsratsvorsitzende fristlos
gekündigt werden
die begründung er hat während der
pandemie zu hause von seinem privaten
rechner an einem dienstplan gearbeitet
und damit angeblich gegen den
datenschutz verstoßen wie primark mit
datenschutz umgeht zeigt dass in dem
betrieb bis vor kurzem noch 128
videokameras angebracht waren
beschäftigte wurden in auf teils räumen
und umkleidekabinen ausspioniert wer hat
da gegen den datenschutz verstoßen meine
damen und herren auf aktuell 3 maria
starbucks h&m oder wie sie alle heißen
das alles zeigt wie die rechte von
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer zur
zeit mit füßen getreten werden
und was macht die bundesregierung ihre
vorschläge sind wirklich nur halbherzig
wahl initiatoren erhalten einen
kündigungsschutz
aber der bei ausserordentlichen und
betriebsbedingten kündigungen nicht
greift betriebsräte können betrieb wie
bei betrieblichen bildungsmaßnahmen die
einigungsstelle anrufen toll aber die
darf nur moderieren bei künstlicher
intelligent intelligenz gelten
sachverständiger als erforderliche
erforderlich aber warum denn nur nahen
und besonders und besonders schritt
finde ich über die regierung zum
datenschutz
nun soll der datenschutzbeauftragte der
durch den arbeitgeber ausgewählt und
bestellt wird ein kontrollrecht
gegenüber dem betriebsrat erhalten
und das hat mit unabhängigkeit des
betriebsrates überhaupt nichts zu tun
die linksfraktion ist nicht bereit
diesen neuen gesetz nach 50 jahren als
großen wurf zu akzeptieren
deshalb werden wir dem uns enthalten bei
der abstimmung vielen dank
[Musik]
und jetzt das kollegin sie hat nicht
beendet was auch der ferienzeit
entsprochen hat ich danke jetzt machen
sie das pult frei das reinigen können
dass wir das klar den kicker anhören
jutta krellmann erstmal noch mal
reagiert auf die wirklich im unteren
reaktionen die wir aus den reihen
insbesondere der spd gekommen sind hat
sie gesagt hat die linke werde sich bei
diesem gesetzentwurf enthalten und
fragte dann wo das problem liegt und hat
dann den bundestagspräsidenten gesagt
sie können auch noch länger reden am
pult davon gehen wir fest aus
nichtsdestotrotz ist jetzt beate müller
gemmeke dran für die fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen aber nicht nur um die
betriebliche mitbestimmung sondern dort
dazu gehört auch ganz zentral die
unternehmensmitbestimmung und deshalb
legen wir ja auch dazu heute einen
antrag vor
die bundesregierung habe hat die
unternehmensmitbestimmung seit jahren
überhaupt nicht im blick obwohl bekannt
ist dass die unternehmen die
mitbestimmung entweder einfach
ignorieren oder bewusst durch ihre
rechtsform vermeiden laut hans böckler
stiftung sind es immerhin 307
unternehmen mit mindestens 2,1 millionen
beschäftigten egal ob stiftungen oder
europäische aktiengesellschaft die
mitbestimmung muss überall gewährleistet
sein und deshalb wollen wir
slitan schließen und die mitbestimmung
in den aufsichtsräten stärken denn
gerade in zeiten von umbrüchen ist die
unternehmensmitbestimmung extrem wichtig
zumindest dass betriebsräte
modernisierungsgesetz kommt hier
profitieren momentan nur 40 prozent der
beschäftigten also von dem betriebsrat
natürlich gibt es belegschaften die
keinen betriebsrat haben wollen aber es
gibt mittlerweile viel zu viele
unternehmens mit mitbestimmungs
feindliche unternehmen und genau dort
brauchen die beschäftigten mehr schutz
vor abmahnungen verkündigung oder
mobbing und deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass jetzt auch die beschäftigten
geschützt werden die erstmalig ein
betriebsrat gründen wollen wir fordern
und es sind übrigens seit 2014
und doch bleiben sie die
regierungsfraktion wie so oft auf halber
strecke stehen der kündigungsschutz ist
in an dieser stelle zwischen schwach und
außerdem bekommen betriebsräte die
sachen los befristet sind keinen schutz
das ist nicht ambitioniert es ist nicht
nicht konsequent und das kritisieren wir
ja und auch
und auch wenn es um die digitalisierung
geht modernisieren sie nur ein bisschen
der betriebs begriff bleibt der alte und
damit lassen sich laut werk und so nur
selbstständige außen vor
bei der qualitativen personalplanung bei
der menge der arbeit abbrechen wie ein
echtes starkes mitbestimmungsrecht und
wichtig wäre natürlich in einer
digitalen arbeitswelt auch ein digitales
zugangsrecht für die gewerkschaften hier
bleiben sie einfach mutlos und das wird
der herausforderung digitalisierung
nicht gerecht wir grünen
wir grünen hätten uns wirklich ein
betriebsräte stärkung setzt gesetz
gewünscht für staaten betriebliche
mitbestimmung auf augenhöhe
und doch ist es gut dass es betriebsräte
modernisierungsgesetz überhaupt kommt es
ist kein großer wurf aber es geht in die
richtige richtung und deshalb werden wir
trotz aller kritik am ende dann
zustimmen
vielen dank die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen das haben wir jetzt von beate
müller gemmeke gehört wird zu diesem
gesetzentwurf der aus dem hause des
bundesministers für arbeit und soziales
kommt zustimmen anders als die
linksfraktion die argumentation beiden
ist gleich richtige richtung aber es
geht nicht weit genug bleibt hinter den
möglichkeiten und notwendigkeiten zurück
aber wie andere sagen und wie
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch kerstin tack
argumentieren wird die sprecherin für
arbeit und soziales in der spd-fraktion
besser einschritt als kaymer
und kollegen wo betriebsräte gemeinsam
mit gewerkschaften arbeiten sind die
arbeitsplätze sicher war die
arbeitsbedingungen besser und die löhne
höher hat der unternehmen mehr als fünf
beschäftigte hat haben die beschäftigten
das recht einen betriebsrat zu gründen
aber abseits der paragraphen im
betriebsverfassungsgesetz sieht die
praxis ein bisschen anders aus denn wir
wissen aus untersuchungen fast jede
sechste gründung von betriebsräten wird
von arbeitgeberseite verhindert oder
blockiert ein skandal
deshalb ist es richtig und wichtig dass
die beschäftigten die sich hier auf den
weg machen weder behindert noch gemobbt
noch versetzt noch gekündigt werden und
genau deshalb ist dieses gesetz richtig
wichtig und stellt die richtigen weichen
mit diesem gesetz setzen wir genau hier
an
wir stärken den beschäftigten den rücken
die eben genau diese betriebsratsarbeit
vorbereiten und die nicht schon aufgrund
des umstandes dass bekannt wird dass sie
überhaupt in gespräche zur gründung
gehen schon erste sanktionen haben
richtig wichtig und erfordern und wir
erweitern das vereinfachte wahlverfahren
machen es für betriebe bis zu 100
beschäftigte obligatorisch
wir senken die schwelle zur aufstellung
des wahlvorschlags aber wir machen mehr
wir verbessern den unfallschutz im
home-office wir senken das wahlalter
auf 16 für die wahl von betriebsräten
wir erhöhen das wahlalter für die wahl
für die jugend und
auszubildendenvertretung wir stärken die
mitbestimmung bei den fragen der
weiterbildung der mobilen arbeit aber
insbesondere bei künstlicher intelligenz
und wir schaffen ein dauerhaftes recht
per video oder telefonschalten
betriebsratssitzung und beschlüsse zu
machen aber nur dann wenn der
betriebsrat ist ausschließlich für sich
so entscheidet miteinander
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch
dieses gesetz hatte einen interessant
langen weg denn wieder so häufig ist in
zeiten wo keine gesetzgebung ansteht
siegen alle das hohelied total
großartiger sozialpartnerschaft in
deutschland und wenn es um konkrete
gesetze geht dann wird das ganze schon
etwas schwierig
dann muss man sich ja genau dazu
bekennen und dann muss man genau diese
stärkung auch in den mittelpunkt stellen
dass das auch an diesen bei diesem
gesetz ein bisschen länger gedauert hat
ist schade aber dass wir heute auch
deutlich über den koalitionsvertrag
hinausgehen und den initiatoren schutz
auch wenn er noch luft nach oben hat
aber wir trotzdem heute die richtigen
weichen stellen ist gut und richtig
und jeder weiß ich habe wohl gehört dass
für die kurzarbeit hier so großartig
gelobt hast umso mehr hoffe ich dass wir
sie jetzt auch gemeinsam verlängern
können bis ende des jahres nicht nur die
kurzarbeit selber sondern auch die höhe
der auszuzahlenden
träge ich glaube auch das wäre ein gutes
zeichen nicht nur für
sozialpartnerschaft sondern für die
beschäftigten in deutschland
das wäre noch ein gutes zeichen dieser
koalition in dieser legislatur natürlich
möchte ich mich auch ganz herzlich
bedanken nicht nur bei der iba hubertus
für deinen unermüdlichen kampf dieses
gesetz über den koalitionsvertrag hinaus
vorzulegen zu verteidigen und heute zum
abschluss mit uns zusammen zu bringen
ich möchte mich bedanken beim bmhs für
wirklich großartige unterstützung und
zuarbeit im parlamentarischen raum und
ganz selbstverständlich bei meiner
großartigen ag für auch in diesem gesetz
super zusammenarbeit herzlichen dank
christian tag war das sprecherin für
arbeit und soziales in der spd-fraktion
und sie hat angedeutet zumindest dass es
ein doch teilweise schwieriger prozess
gewesen ist auch innerhalb der koalition
diesen gesetzentwurf so weit zu bringen
wo er heute ist nämlich kurz vor der
verabschiedung die unionsseite sah sich
häufig der kritik ausgesetzt den vorgang
zu verschleppen und zu blockieren einen
das wird ist jetzt stephan stracke
schildern aus der unionsfraktion
sprecher der landesgruppe csu
landesgruppe für die themen arbeit und
soziales die wirtschaftlichen erfolge
auch stabiler und die betriebliche
mitbestimmung ist gut für deutschland
und deswegen brauchen wir mehr
betriebsräte in deutschland nicht
weniger und damit dies besser gelingt
wollen wir beispielsweise das wahlalter
von 18 auf 16 jahren absenken das
schafft mehr demokratische legitimität
für die betriebsräte und betriebliche
mitbestimmung geht eine freilich nur im
miteinander und nicht im gegeneinander
das akzeptieren wir beispielsweise im
datenschutzrecht der arbeitgeber
verantwortlich für den betrieb natürlich
auch für den betriebsrat aber er braucht
für seine erfüllung seiner aufgaben
letztendlich auch ein vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit unterstützung und das
stellen wir klar und waren dabei auch
die besondere stellung des betriebsrats
und dasselbe gilt im übrigen auch für
die erleichterte möglichkeit des
betriebsrats bei der einführung und
anwendung von künstlicher intelligenz
dessert externen sachverstand
hinzuziehen kann
und selbstverständlich bleibt es dabei
vorher im betrieb zunächst einmal nach
betrieblichen know-how ausschau zu
halten und diesen zu nutzen bevor auch
diese externe sachverstand eingeholt
wird und das stärkt die zusammenarbeit
sollte eine selbstverständlichkeit sein
und dort wurde es nicht gegeben ist
halte ich an dieser stelle auch eine
stärkung für wichtig angesichts der
zunehmend digitalisiert das technisch
und des technologischen fortschritts ist
weiterbildung und qualifikation
natürlich zentral wir wollen dass die
beschäftigten von heute auch die arbeit
von morgen erfüllen können und deswegen
stärken wir auch an dieser stelle die
rechte der betriebsräte sie wir wollen
das hier konkrete maßnahmen der
berufsausbildung auch tatsächlich
vereinbart werden dass befördern werden
und die mobile arbeit hat in der hand
die einen massiven schub erfahren
auch hier erhalten betriebsräte bei der
ausgestaltung von mobiler arbeit ein
mitbestimmungsrecht um einen
einheitlichen verbindlichen rechtsrahmen
für den betrieb schaffen zu können und
mehr mobile arbeit bedeutet ja auch
gleichzeitig nicht weniger sozialen
schutz und aus diesem grund haben wir
beispielsweise bei den gesetzlichen
unfallversicherungsschutz die mobile
arbeit hier verbessert es darf ja keinen
unterschied machen ob ich von zu hause
arbeiten oder vom betrieb aus und das
stellen wir sicher
gleiches gilt im übrigen auch für
wegeunfälle beispielsweise zum
kindergarten oder zurück bei der
ausgestaltung und zusammenarbeit
zwischen arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmern
gibt es natürlich immer wieder
interessenskonflikte ich finde dass wir
einen sehr austarierten gesetzesentwurf
vorlegen
ich bitte um zustimmung stephan stracke
für die unionsfraktion im büro und genau
zu sein sprecher der csu landesgruppe
für die themen arbeit und soziales und
ans pult begibt sich marco bülow
inzwischen fraktionslos vor nicht allzu
langer zeit mitglied der spd fraktion
präsident sehr geehrte damen und herren
wenn aus einem betriebsräte stärkung
gesetz ein betriebsräte
modernisierungsgesetz wird dann weiß man
eigentlich schon was die stunde
geschlagen hat und dass die union am
ende wieder ganze arbeit geleistet hat
denn wir bräuchten mehr als nur
modernisierungen wir bräuchten eben
genau diese stärkung und die ist nur
wenn überhaupt in ansätzen vorhanden ich
glaube das ist immer noch unterschätzt
wird was da am werk ist das ist klare
kriminalitäts und das ist importiert aus
den usa dass es anwaltskanzleien gibt
dass agenturen gibt die nichts anderes
machen als betriebe auszuschlachten und
genau das einzuführen dass betriebsräte
dort gar keine chance mehr habe bevor
sie diese firmen dann weitergeben und
dann diese firma auch einen höheren
marktwert hat weil es dort keine
betriebsrat ergibt das ist kriminelle
energie und die muss richtig bestraft
werden deswegen müssen wir über ein ganz
anderes strafmaß bei sie sind gesetz
sprechen beispielsweise über
datenschutzes schon geredet worden
auch die sachgrundlose befristung des
angesprochen worden übrigens die
sachgrundlose befristung ein großer
punkt im koalitionsvertrag bis jetzt ist
da nicht viel von spürbar dass sich das
viel geändert hat auf dem arbeitsmarkt
nur als randbemerkung
zudem müsste ein melderegister
eingeführt werden was das ganze
verbindlicher macht dann wären wir ein
schnitt weiter
gestern gab es eine kundgebung von
betriebsräten die genau diese punkte
deutlich gemacht haben und die mehr
einfordern als das was jetzt hier
vorliegt sie haben auch eine lange
unterschriftenliste und her
bewährtes heil sie warten darauf wir
haben mehrfach versucht mit ihm kontakt
aufzunehmen ministerium diese
unterschriften zu übergeben und weiter
noch mit ihm im gespräch zu bleiben
vielleicht kümmern sie sich darum
denn eigentlich müssten wir heute
darüber eine anders
selbst sprechen was gleichzeitig
ausgehandelt worden dass man nennt das
wohl kuhhandel ein gesetz sozusagen auf
der anderen seite die saison
arbeiterstadt 70 tage 100 tage hier
arbeiten dürfen mit schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen mit schlechten
unterbringung mit keiner
krankenversicherung das ist gleichzeitig
im prinzip wahrscheinlich ausgehandelt
worden
und genau solche kuhhandel brauchen wir
nicht sondern wir brauchen eine stärkung
der betriebsräte darauf wert angekommen
vielen dank marco bülow hatte gerade mal
zwei minuten in dieser debatte und wir
sind beim letzten redner in dieser
debatte angekommen wie gesagt 30 minuten
nicht besonders tolle viel für ein
gesetz das sich mit der betrieblichen
mitbestimmung beschäftigte aber die zeit
drängt am ende dieser 19
legislaturperiode marktplatz ist
mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales und mitglied der unionsfraktion
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrter herr minister heil
ja herr bülow wir machen hier keine
kuhhandel sondern wir machen gesetze das
ist der große unterschied was wir heute
hier machen deswegen finde ich diesen
ausdruck nicht richtig aber ich lasse
ihnen der aktions losen gerne dann auch
so stimmen vor über 100 jahren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wurde in
deutschland die ersten betriebsräte
gegründet zu diesem zeitpunkt gab es
noch keine tonfilm es gab noch kein
internet es gab keine künstliche
intelligenz von big data wussten wir
noch gar nicht dass es irgendwann mal
kommen wird seitdem hat sich viel
geändert
unsere heutige bundesrepublik
deutschland eine stolze demokratie baut
auf die sozialpartnerschaft auf die
betriebliche mitbestimmung als fundament
unserer sozialen marktwirtschaft daher
müssen die damen bitte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wird
diese sozialpartnerschaft zukunftsfest
gemacht werden
und das hat nicht zuletzt die korona
pandemie uns gezeigt 1972 wurde das
betriebsverfassungsgesetz eingeführt und
vor 20 jahren wurde es zum letzten mal
der formiert also wir brauchen dringend
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein
update und dieses update wird die
betriebsräte digitaler und agiler machen
als digital politiker und
arbeitsmarktpolitiker bietet die
digitalisierung gerade für die
betriebliche mitbestimmung ein großes
pfund und das sollten wir heute auch
umsetzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mit dem
betriebsräte modernisierungsgesetz gehen
wir heute einen wichtigen schritten an
dieser stelle möchte ich gerade als
junger abgeordneter meinem kollegen dem
uwe schummer und dem bernd rützel noch
einmal danken die berichterstatter
wandeln die einfachen guten job gemacht
haben danke euch zwei die pandemie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen hat die ganze
betriebsratsarbeit auf den kopf gesetzt
und deswegen sind wir jetzt richtig auf
dem richtigen weg dass wir sagen wir
müssen jetzt hier digitaler werden und
wir können eben auch mehr leisten
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch
bei der künstlichen intelligenz müssen
eben die betriebsräte ihre kompetenz
weitergeben können hier haben wir auch
eine gute regelung dass eben dann auch
intern und wie externer sachverstand mit
dazu genommen werden kann
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
finde es schade und traurig dass heute
die anderen kollegen von der fdp
von den linken auch von der afg nicht
zustimmen oder sich enthalten
damit machen wir eine falsche politik
denn es geht darum heute hier nicht vor
den werken mit parolen zu stehen sondern
in den werken etwas besser zu machen und
dafür ist dieses gesetz genau richtig
ich bitte um ihre zustimmung auch die
sich noch nicht entschlossen haben
fielen
dank man die damen und herren klassen
ein guter tag heute mit diesem
betriebsräte modernisierungsgesetz
dankeschön
damit schließt sich die aussprache zu
tagesordnungspunkt 37 grad kommen wir
jetzt zur abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur förderung der
betriebsratswahlen der
betriebsratsarbeit in einer digitalen
arbeitswelt der ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales empfiehlt unter buchstabe a
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf der
drucksache 29 8 19
den gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
auf druck und 28 8 99 sekunden 29 6 31
in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen ich
bitte diejenigen die dem gesetzentwurf
indisches fassung zustimmen wollen dass
anzeigen dass die koalition und bündnis
90/die grünen wäre stimmt dagegen die
fdp die fdp
er enthält sich die linie der
gesetzentwurf ist in zweiter lesung
angenommen dritte beratung zur
abstimmung mit ihren sieben entwurf
zustimmen wollen sich zu erheben
da einige sehr bestimmt dagegen der
serbe enthält sich der gesetzentwurf ist
der mit denselben mehrheiten angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 37 b wir setzen die
abstimmung zu der beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für arbeit und soziales
auf drucksachen 29 8 19 ford unter
buchstabe b sache beschlussempfehlung
empfiehlt der ausschuss die ablehnung
des antrags der fraktion der fdp auf der
drucksache so meine damen und herren
jetzt der gesetzentwurf ein gesetz
jedenfalls was den bundestag angeht da
gibt es ja noch die eine und andere
formate bis hin zum bundespräsidenten
wie er das immer noch als unterzeichner
muss bevor es dann in kraft treten kann
aber dem wird jetzt nichts weiter im
wege stehen insofern kann
bundesarbeitsminister heil dem wir
gerade sehen entspannt mehr oder weniger
wahrscheinlich aber zumindest was dieses
gesetz an geht entspannt wir zurück in
sein büro fahren
der bundestag stimmt jetzt über eine
ganze reihe von anträgen ab die sich mit
dem feld und mit dem themenbereich
insgesamt beschäftigen wir hatten schon
einen antrag des gebiet falsch ich fange
mal von vorne an acht anträge liegen vor
vier aus der linksfraktion drei von den
grünen einmal aus einer aus der fdp und
die werden hier erwartungsgemäß keine
mehrheiten finden dass er hat auch schon
das schicksal ereilt den antrag
entsprechend der fdp betriebsrat 4.0 ist
ein titel
potenziale der digitalisierung nutzen
und genauso ergangen ist es mit einem
antrag der linken demokratisierung der
arbeitswelt betriebliche mitbestimmung
ausweiten und modernisieren hat auch
keine mehrheit gefunden ebenso wie auch
der jetzt gerade besprochen oder
beziehungsweise aufgerufene antrag der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
unternehmensmitbestimmung stärken
gesetzeslücken schließen
und weiter geht's mit noch vier anträgen
die hieraus stehen diesmal geht es um
den vorne fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
betriebsratswahlen erleichtern aktive
beschäftigte besser schützen
die fdp besteht dagegen die linke wer
enthält sich bündnis 90 die grünen bis
elvis angenommen unter buchstabe also
was lieber mal verwirrung auszuschließen
es gibt halt beschlussempfehlungen aus
dem ausschuss für arbeit und soziales da
sind die mehrheiten in natürlich genauso
wie hier im plenum und das heißt wenn
ihr anträge aus der opposition kommen
dann ist die beschlussempfehlung die
diese anträge abzulehnen aber hier wird
natürlich an der englischen entschluss
beschlussempfehlung zugestimmt
kann man schon mal durcheinander kommen
aber im grunde ist es ist so schwer dann
auch wieder nicht wir sind wieder einen
schritt weiter sind bestürmen bei dem
antrag aus der fraktion der grünen noch
mal betriebsratswahlen erleichtern
aktive beschäftigte besser schütz haus
ist im video gebucht habe zu einer
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
29 25 den antrag der fraktion bündnis 90
grünen auf der drucksache 17 10
abzulehnen bestimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung und die koalition
afd fdp bestimmt dagegen bündnis 90 die
grünen und die linke
die beschlussempfehlung angenommen unter
buchstabe b empfiehlt der ausschuss die
ablehnung des antrags der fraktion
bündnis 90 grünen auf der burg sache 16
8 43 mit dem titel digitalisierung
update für die mitbestimmung mehr stimmt
für diese mission empfehle koalition afd
fdp bestimmt dagegen wollen sich die
grünen zu wenig angenommen tagesordnung
bitte und die linke bündnis 90 grünen
die linke ja man versucht immer schnell
zu machen wenn wir an das ende des tages
denkt tages augsburg 37
aber jetzt stehen noch zwei anträge aus
ihr beide aus der linksfraktion in dem
einen heißt dass das geld
massenentlassungen zu verhindern die
mitbestimmung auszubauen und der andere
heißt oder dritte titel
betriebsratswahlen erleichtern und
betriebsräte besser schützen das haben
wir dann auch aus den anderen fraktionen
der opposition durchaus schon gehört und
es wird auch diese beiden anträge das
schicksal ereilen dass sie ihr keine
mehrheit finden